it's always interesting to talk to
neuroscientists about genius I mean we
use the word genius all the time we can
call Picasso a genius or Ernst and a
genius or your five-year-old a genius if
he's particularly good at his arithmetic
but for a neuroscientist you know you
you must be thinking about this in terms
of the brain what's going on in the
brain of a genius so I'm curious like
for you what is the word genius mean
genius calls to mind the questions of
individual differences as a
neuroscientist we always think of the
brain as being the source of our
characteristics our personality our
talents and genius is on the scale of
talents that relationship between the
neural circuitry of the brain and how
the brain is organized it works and how
we actually behave and what talents we
have is really the essence of
neuroscience so it's kind of about the
diversity of the wiring you're saying I
mean that you have different kinds of
wiring that lead to different levels of
talent in different areas well it's an
interesting question we really don't
know what it is about our brains that
makes your brain different than my brain
the truth of the matter is most of our
brains are pretty similar and the subtle
differences in anatomy and structure of
the brain oftentimes result in very big
differences in who we are how we think
and what our talents are so it gets very
complicated very fast and the best
answer is we really don't know there's a
review but do we have any hunches maybe
like I mean could it be well I'm just
thinking like could it be a question say
of you know a thicker layer of neurons
here or a stronger connection between
two regions there I mean do we have a
sense of what what might be underlying
like these sort of extreme cases like
you know what what you know what we
should be leaving looking for it's clear
that there's not a simple answer to that
question that the
with the thick cortical layer isn't
necessarily the brain that is the most
talented brain but I think that it's
worth going back and thinking about a
little bit what is genius
because it means different things to
different people and perhaps even in
different times in our life or when I
think of genius I think of the creative
person the person who changes the way we
think the person that has an impact
often times that that lasts long after
the person is passed on and that
creative seed is something that's very
difficult for neuroscientists to
understand it's not like this one little
part of the brain that makes us creative
mm-hmm it's something about how the
whole brain works together right it is
it is tricky and I mean geniuses are
sort of by definition rare and and you
know when you're working as a scientist
you don't like rare I mean you like to
be able to look at a whole bunch of
people a whole bunch of brains and look
for things in common so I mean people
have tried to look at Albert Einstein's
brain to figure out what his genius is I
mean what do you think of that kind of
work well actually I think it's a little
misguided to tell you the truth that
looking at the anatomy of a brain it's
very difficult to understand much of the
function but I think that we don't have
to think of genius as being something
that is rare I think we can imagine that
there's a little genius in all of us all
of us really yes we're all creative you
for example you're one of the most
creative science writers that there is
well but I'm not going to like thank you
but I'm not gonna like solve Fermat's
Last Theorem you know I'm not going to
paint Guernica there are lots of things
that I'm definitely not going to do and
I'm definitely not going to be called a
genius well I'm not so sure that the
quality of genius isn't necessarily a
continuum a continuum of creativity a
contingent in uum of yank
ingenuity I think all of us as humans
are sort of endowed with the need to
make things better to invent things to
go beyond the borders we're all pioneers
roam we're all fascinated with a
frontier I mean why do we think we need
to go to the moon or to Mars it's
because we're human and we want to know
what's on the other side and it's so
ingrained in us that I think that genius
genius is just an extreme version of
that but it represents us as humans in a
very fundamental way so in a way it
might be actually more interesting to
compare all of us as a species to other
species and look at how our brains are
working or how they're different and
what the things that we can do with our
brains compared to chimpanzees or
gorillas or crows or what-have-you
yeah actually I think that that's a very
logical extension of what I've just said
that that it's very unique among species
on the planet to be as creative as we
are mm-hmm it's really the essence I
think of who we are as humans
you